e
everyone
it being a little past 9:00
we'll call to order the house Judiciary
Committee and we will begin as usual by
pledging Allegiance and representative
Smith would you like to lead us today in
Allegiance allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you can be seated Mr clerk
role
here
here good morning everyone our first
item of business today is a hearing it's
a hearing on Senate Bill 399 FN relative
to certain provisions of the fetal Life
protection act requiring an ultrasound
examination I have a number of cards
this
morning uh what we have done in the past
is uh We've uh and I want to just Begin
by saying that everyone who has signed
in so far has signed up in support of
the bill no one has signed up in
opposition to the bill
today what we typic Ty Al do is allow
the sponsors to talk uh for up to five
minutes to introduce the bill and I
would and generally what we try to do is
hold everybody to approximately three
minutes in uh speaking time
today and and frankly only I think only
one person's asked for a little bit more
than three
minutes the primary sponsor of this bill
is Senator Rosenwald and I see Senator
Rosenwald you're there would you like to
introduce your bill today thank you Mr
chairman for the record I am Cindy
rosenal from Senate District 13 which is
the majority part of nashwa and I will
not be speaking for five minutes um I'm
here to introduced Senate Bill
399 this bill will clarify that
ultrasound is only required prior to
performing an abortion at least 24 weeks
into pregnancy we we've been told that
it was never the intention of the 24
week band sponsors the original
sponsors that um ultrasound would be
required in all cases therefore it's
important to make this
clarification and remove an unnecessary
procedure and expense to patients when
ultrasound is not the clinical standard
of Care thank you Mr chair
thank you are there any questions for
Senator
rosenell seeing none thank you for your
brief testimony
huitt
I think you have to turn on the
microphone there's a old button there
there you go can hear me now Ian hwit uh
in support of Senate Bill 399 this
discussion together a number of times
and I will not repeat myself
unnecessarily I'll just point to the
implications of some changed
circumstances the house has of course
passed House Bill 1609 which creates an
exception would create an exception to
our current law for cases of fa fatal
fetal abnormalities that means two
things that are important should the
committee consider an amendment which
removes enforcement capacity from our
current law Andor which creates an
open-ended exception first at least as
far as the house is concerned we are now
talking about a law which is even more
moderate than the law which was in place
in Massachusetts prior to December of
2020 which was a 24 week abortion
prohibition with no exception for fetal
anomal
secondly because the house has already
spoken on the issue of fatal fetal
abnormalities should the committee
pursue the kind of amendment that I
describe the children whose deaths would
be authorized would be children who are
both older than 24 and are medically VI
in other words children who could have
lived had they been delivered instead of
killed on the day of their abor it's not
unlike of course some of the children
whose corpses were recently discovered
in Washington DC C which is a
jurisdiction where the abortion provider
who killed them will not face so much as
a parking ticket that is the same
impunity that an abortion provider would
have enjoyed in New Hampshire prior to
January of this year I pray that that
fact would be of some moral significance
to the members of the committee thank
you and I would be happy to take any
questions about the bill the law or
related legal
issues are there any questions for Mr
hwit
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Montgomery good morning uh members of
the Judiciary Committee my name is Kayla
Montgomery I am the vice president of
Republic Affairs for Planned Parenthood
Northern New England and our sister
action fund we are here today to support
Senate Bill 399 and I will stick to the
bill before you um this committee is uh
you know has a lot of background on this
bill already so I very brief um prior to
January 1st of
2022 this year conducting an ultrasound
prior to an abortion was up to a
clinician's uh best medical judgment the
provider could work directly with the
patient on whether an ultrasound was
necessary but on January 1st the
ultrasound provision went into effect
and it is written in such a way that
requires all patients in New Hampshire
seeking an abortion to undergo an
ultrasound whether medically necessary
or not this provision is currently
impacting patients who are seeking
abortion care early in pregnancy so
those who are prior to 11 weeks uh know
the date of their last menstration and
have uh no risk
factors the ultrasound for those
patients are not always medically
necessary but they are now required to
have one under the current law so under
this current law again ultrasounds are
mandatory no matter the individual
circumstance or the recommend
recommendation of the clinician so we
support Senate Bill 399 because it
clarifies the ultrasound requirement in
relation to the newly enacted abortion
bin so rather than prior to all abortion
care which is the current law so this
bill before you is one of three bills um
that would currently address the
ultrasound requirement the other being
House Bill
1673 uh which will be on the senate
floor tomorrow same language and then of
course House Bill 1609 which passed out
of the house with broad bipartisan
support just last month again that is
the same language as well but in terms
of this bill before you we would ask you
to uh pass this current bill sen Bill
399 I'm happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions from
Miss
Montgomery thank you zingan thank you
Stapleton waler Stapleton Claremont W 3
Sullivan County District 5 I rise in
support of SP 399
FN and um I'm happy that uh the
amendment 03 33s uh was incorporated
into the bill to provide that Clarity
that we need to um uh for the ultrasound
at or near the 24-week
period it's time
to affirm this bill in in our
legislature in our law body uh to
protect um viable life in the womb in
the third
trimester while this bill it still gives
us
reasonable um ability for people to make
decisions in the first and second
trimester uh so if there's any question
about what to do or when to do it uh
there's there's fully 6 months for um a
woman and her family a partner to make
that
decision most of the abortions uh by the
statistics occur in the first
trimester and some then in the second
very few much much fewer in in the third
and this is when life is viable this is
when we have a living breathing well not
yet breathing but a living and viable um
child
in the womb and to take that life that
late is a travesty and I'm glad that New
Hampshire is at the point where we can
step back from that travesty and write
this uh good
legislation into law and uh I'm hoping
that uh you you will pass it and uh it
will be affirmed in our statutes to
protect that viable and valuable and
any
questions sorry any questions for
representative Stapleton singan thank
you for your testimony
it as just stated my name is Sarah H and
I want to thank you for the opportunity
to speak today My Hope Is that today
Bill SB 399 will not be turned into a
gutting bill for the
flpa that is the Fatal Life protection
act there have been multiple attempts
this year for that bill to be or act to
be changed or modified to not protect
The Unborn I understand many of those in
support of abortion want to remove the
flpa since abortion is seen as a morally
correct act after all it protects
woman's rights as a woman I am full in
support of Rights for my sex the issue
with abortion however is not over
woman's rights as often portrayed many
different arguments raised distract from
the core issue when does an embryo
become human to be clear when I use the
word human I'm referring to someone
equal to the rest of humanity in value
and who has the right to life if an
embryo is not a human there's no issue
with abortion if the embryo is human
then abortion is murder every other
matter is secondary to this one question
once it's resolved any other matter
regarding abortion can be easily
answered five elements change between
conception and birth regarding the
embryo size level of development
environment degree of dependency and
level of Consciousness let's start with
size how does size give human life value
humans range in different sizes but does
not affect the value we have or the
rights we possess as American citizens
human value is greater than physical
appearance level of development born
babies are less developed than children
children are less developed than teens
when does level of development make
someone else more valued environment
someone's environment does not change
their value someone cannot travel to any
location in the universe and become less
valuable to say a child's value hinges
on the Journey of 8 Ines is ridiculous
why bother with a C-section if they're
not valuable until outside the womb
degree of dependency the comos and
disabled are all dependent on others
born babies are dependent on their
Guardians if not more so than an embryo
degree of Consciousness Consciousness
does not impact value someone in a coma
is not less valuable someone with a
severe mental disorder is not less
valuable in the end what makes a human
valuable is that they are human there's
no extra criteria for a human to have
worth the minute someone tries to place
one on an embryo there will always be
another human that is an exception when
did Being Human no longer be enough to
have the right to life abortion is not
protecting woman's rights nor is it
moral I hope today you'll let BS 399
pass without modifying it to remove more
of the
flpa in the future I hope you will
continue to fight for the rights of
those who cannot speak for themselves
thank you for your
time are there any questions from M
hole seeing none thank you for your
testimony
manasi good morning and thank you for
the opportunity to speak here today good
morning I am Karen I am Karen manasi I'm
a retired occupational therapist with
degrees and
biology and occupational therapy I'm
also the mother of three twin Sons
and a child whose life ended in an
abortion clinic over 30 years ago I'm
here to urge the committee to vote ought
to pass on Senate Bill 399 as amended by
the Senate by doing so you would be
strengthening an already sound late term
abortion ban in a state that protects
viably late term children just weeks
before their birth I oppose any attempt
to amend the law and Committee in a way
that would render it unenforceable
and incapable of Defending even a single
child much has been made of the need to
give women absolute say over whether the
child they carry lives or dies but few
speak of that child who through no fault
of their own is killed before even being
able to take a single breath outside the
womb a child's right to live can't only
be based on whether they are convenient
or wanted certainly we can B reasonable
protections for viable pre-born while
still providing women ample opportunity
to seek an abortion if that is their
decision to hear those who oppose any
restrictions you would think
women always make loving supportive and
knowledgeable decisions to terminate the
young lives they
carry that was not my
experience as a young woman like so many
I was faced with an unexpected pregnancy
with a father who did not want the
child unsupported afraid and panicked I
scraped up the money for an abortion and
I walked in
alone no one had told me the violence of
what was to
felt the pain of having life torn out of
your body by force you couldn't
understand there was no connection no
compassion from the Doctor Who Never
introduced herself to
me and never acknowledged
me before painfully violating my body
and ending the life of my
child and this was in my first three
months of
pregnancy we need to take a moment and
think about these fully formed children
in the last trimester
on what has to happen to forcibly in
their
lives we argue on the margins of extreme
examples and ignore those children who
have a true chance at life a 24-week ban
with exceptions for the health of the
mother is not
extreme and for those women who still
want to abort their late term children
there are bordering states that would be
happy to accommodate
them just as New Hampshire no doubt did
when we had abortion on demand for any
reason up to the uh moment of birth I
urge the committee to pass Senate Bill
399 as currently amended by the Senate
and keep these modest Protections in
place for those who cannot defend
themselves thank you for
listening are there any
today
Azam good
morning um my name is Laura al-azam I'm
from londonairy and if you don't mind
I'm just going to look at my notes for a
quick moment
um I I have had the opportunity to talk
to people in my community about uh the
bills that are before the legislature
this year regarding the 24 week abortion
restriction um and most of them
understand what the fetal Life
protection act is and that it was just
recently enacted and they're wondering
why we would mess with it so quickly
after it was enacted you know why don't
we just give it a chance to work and see
how it goes most of them like a strong
majority of New Hampshire citizens and
Americans support restrictions on
abortion and they recognize that what we
have now has moved New Hampshire from an
extreme position enabling abortion up
until birth um to a more mainstream
albeit still permissive um abortion
position and most are familiar with the
ultrasound procedure and were kind of
baffled to hear over the course of last
summer and fall that um there was a
media campaign that very aggressively
pushed the ultrasound wording as um
intrusive extraord orinary extreme and
really that portrayal was just baffling
to most of the people i' had spoken with
who had been pregnant before and gone
through the usual doctor's appointments
but given this bad information in the
media I do support the clarification of
the ultrasound wording um and therefore
I just strongly support um SB 399 as
amended by the Senate and I hope that
you will um pass it as such and not
change the wording in any ways now thank
are there any questions from the
committee singan thank you for your
testimony
petal need to take the box away good
morning and thank you for hearing my
testimony and support of Senate Bill 399
as amended by the Senate this is the
second time this session that I have
come before the house Judiciary
Committee I have also testified
regarding House Bill
1673 considering the similarity between
these bills that written testimony is
included as well my name is Katie
peternell I live in wolfboro with my
husband we raised four daughters there I
have a Bachelor of Science and nursing I
stand before you today as a woman who
has had far too many experiences
surrounding life issues as an adopte as
a birth mother as the grandmother of a
beautiful 5-month-old grandson from an
unplanned unwed pregn pry as a friend of
women who have shared their stories of
abortion as an attendee of retreats to
heal the suffering of post-abortive
women and the mother of a son who was
delivered early at 23 weeks gestation I
think I have a very valid opinion on the
fetal Life protection act and attempts
to amend or repeal it of all of my
experiences I think that the most
pertinent to today's hearing is the
emergent delivery of my son at 23 weeks
in order to save one life as opposed to
losing two he was delivered via
C-section followed by a hysterectomy the
surgery to save my life lasted 8 hours
and and required the transfusion of four
units of blood this decision was not one
my husband and I took lightly and I was
willing to Die to Save the life of my
son the night before the surgery I will
never forget lying in the hospital bed
feeling my son kicking and moving around
he was very active while I lay there I
kept silently asking him to please stop
moving please stop moving after the
surgery they brought the body of my
23-week old son to me although I was in
the stuper of anesthesia I can still 18
years later see that perfectly formed
body an entire human being a baby only
one week younger than the narrow
ultrasound requirement in Senate Bill
399 when you vote on this bill as
amended by the Senate please think about
what a 24-week just station baby looks
like and vote to support this Bill thank
you thank you are there any questions
from the committee cenan thank you for
coming and for your testimony
hole okay uh he signed in in support any
handy good morning I'm Greg handy from
Bedford a retired military officer
father of
six um first of all I want to thank you
as our
Representatives because I know it's not
an easy job and it takes a lot of time
and
commitment I am here in support of the
bill and of
life I'm here to help support you in
fulfilling your moral duty before
God because he said we shall not
kill also to support you and your duty
to the
Constitution which is to protect the
life and Liberty of every human being
born and unborn
collectively we have a duty and you are
our conscience
sing us to enact laws that conform to
God when the Supreme Court in
73 allowed abortion it was a violation
against the law of God and and the
Constitution and your duty our
Collective duty is to change it it's
it's not an
option I
was I think 14 watching Walter kronite
with my father hearing the announcement
of that decision and my father who had a
career in human
services taking care of the mentally
physically disabled said to me Greg
you'll get worse as bad as this
is you'll see the death of the elderly
and the force killing of the disabled
and you may say that doesn't happen now
will Cas from Point University of
Pittsburgh publicized on their
website their
experiments of taking live Human tissue
off of aborted babies Eng grafting them
on
rodents they're also doing similar
procedures with other
organs and from a foil
request we learned that the US
government and its academic
Partners prefer fresh and never Frozen
baby body
parts meaning that the specimens these
alive I I can't believe that we're
debating that whether there's human life
here or not we know that life begins at
conception from the union of the sperm
Egg and I lost my train of thought
here but if there's any doubt it's to
look at photos of aborted
babies and it's
gruesome and these babies
from uh to where you really can't
discern the form to where they're fully
formed and those are the photos that we
all need to look at to remind ourselves
of this
Duty what is abortion there's many types
this the use of medication that causes
the
premature
miscarriage of the child there's a dil
dilation in
curage where the baby is basically
sucked out of the womb and often times
dismembered through that
procedure there's dilation and and an
evacuation where the baby's actually
physically dismembered and suctioned out
and then there's induction abortion
where the baby's injected with a poison
that cause cardiac arrest and induced
labor often the woman's has to carry
that baby dead for two or three days
before the body naturally expels
it this is not just to the baby or to
what's even more upsetting is that 40 50
years ago this would have been we we
would have been a gast at this it's
these types of crimes which nberg after
the defeat of Nazi Germany the
trials were held to hold
account on these
abuses part of what nberg went after
were crimes against humanity which were
defined as murder
extermination enslavement deportment and
other inhumane acts committed against
any civil
population in response many of the
perpetrators were held to
Justice and what resulted was a nberg
code 10
points three of which are most relevant
one the voluntary consent of the human
subject is absolutely
essential the next the experiment should
be avoided or I should say should be
conducted as to avoid all unnecessary
physical and mental suffering and
injury and the next is no experiment
should be conducted where there is a
aprior reason to believe that death or
disabling injury will will
occur
well abortion goes Way Beyond this as we
know it takes to life if it didn't why
procedure so in
conclusion I think it's quite obvious
what the moral duty is the duty before
God the duty in conformance to the
Constitution and I ask that you always
support the right to life and thank you
for your
help
thank you for your testimony are there
any
questions seeing none thank you
Chester thank you committee chair thank
you sorry thank you committee chair
thank you committee members my name is
russan Chester I'm a resident of Bedford
New Hampshire and uh I am um I was born
in the 60s but uh I was fortunate enough
not to uh have a lot of problems even
though I was born premature um and
possibly um at that at or right around
that 24 we gation period
um that being said uh I think anytime
we're taking out ultrasounds it the the
abortion process process is different
depending on what trimester the woman is
in not having an ultrasound in the
the for second or third term trimesters
you are taking the chance of not only
not only having a botched abortion and
I'm sure you folks now have seen a lot
of these babies that have been born um
who are now young children and teenagers
from these botched abortions if you
haven't check it out it's pretty awful
that what they've gone through um with
regards to that third trimester
abortions are extremely dangerous for um
it being a botched abortion but it's
also extremely D dangerous for the woman
who's made that choice it's something
they don't tell you I I am um someone
who had an abortion because I thought it
was my right my body my choice I had an
abortion and I finally realized 15 years
later that that choice carried a lot of
consequences for me it carried a lot of
consequences emotionally and physically
I lied about how far along I was on
purpose so that I could have the
entitled I beg all of you to really look
at this I've just found out last night
that according to our state laws if a
woman dies during the abortion process
the the abortion clinic is not required
to
notify the coroner they notify next they
notify their emergency contact and the
emergency contact does that that's part
of the reason why we don't see women in
our state dying from botched
abortions um I suspect I need to look
2022 to prevent abortions there's
absolutely no reason to have to to to to
be to be um doing this kind of process
at least without the ultrasound um being
included um and I feel most importantly
that provided the appropriate education
if these um clinics truly provided the
appropriate education to the woman about
all the different options that are
available to them that we would see
abortion go down drastically I also am
um a birth mom I released a child for
adoption after my abortion 15 years
later I found myself pregnant
again this time I made the adoption
option available for her
because I had learned how traumatic the
choice of abortion is for women thank
you you are there any questions from the
committee represent Horgan did you have
a
question yeah sure uh Miss Chester I
know you've been heavily involved in the
childbearing age who are pregnant who've
died from covid um and I don't know if
you if you know the number you can
probably if you happen to know the
number you can share it with us or maybe
not because that involves both the death
of not just the mother but of uh the
fetus or sometimes two or three fetuses
carrying I think I need you to repeat
the question I don't know how that how
what that has to do with this bill
before us today okay so um I was just I
was just asking about the issue of
pregnant women who die of covid and in
which case they're not just uh you're
not just losing the uh the pregnant
woman but you're also losing the baby or
in some cases some cases multiple
fetuses who the woman is carrying and
well the interesting part of that is if
you identify that the the the the the
thing that is growing inside the woman's
stomach as a baby then abortion should
be a crime against humanity
if you don't if you ident if you say no
it's just a bunch of cells then that's a
different story but that's the bottom
line here so I guess first we have to
identify what is a baby um you know when
does when does that gestational age
become a baby if you want to say okay at
25 weeks it's a baby um then that's
another story is that they
don't
particularly they they don't ever ever
justalot of situations some of these
some of these pregnant women that have
died from covid have died from the
treatments of the covid-19 um situation
and not actually from covid so it's very
hard to tease out right now we're only
two years in to what is we don't know
what the vaccine is going to do to the
unborn baby or if you don't recognize it
as a baby then the fetus um we don't
know the long-term effects for covid-19
and or the vaccine at this point so um I
do know that more women have died more
pregnant women have died from car
accidents and their babies have died
from car accidents than they have from
covid-19 thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question just I just
wanted to clarify your position a little
bit because um are are you in support of
the bill or do you think that it goes
too far with respect to um removing some
of the requirements for ultrasound so
just looking to clarify what your
position was on the bill I I want to re
because I didn't have the bill before
the amendment was in so I want to read
through it I will um send an email
whether or not I I support or oppose I
was in a different hearing um but one of
the things I want to be clear is that I
I I understand that because of R versus
Wade and because we have granted women
the choice and I'm not going to go there
as whether that was right or wrong it's
history what I'm saying is is that look
at what we did with prohibition that
didn't work so becoming so making
abortion completely a legal in our state
may not be the way to go because then
again we're putting women in position
that they're still going to do it
they're just going to have to do it
without appropriate oversight and Care
um personally what I would like to see
is I would like to see uh a lot more a
lot more reporting with regards to um
the respon on the responsibility of the
uh agencies that are performing these
abortions and that uh having an
ultrasound involved would would help to
start making those numbers come a little
more to light in the state of New
Hampshire thank you thank you for your
testimony
hole
thank you chairman can everybody hear
me good so I'm going to start by reading
from our
constitution because as best I can tell
there's no carve outs regarding the age
of the person part first article two all
men have natural certain sorry all men
have certain natural essential and
inherent rights among them which are
enjoying and defending life and Liberty
acquiring possess and possessing and
protecting property and in a word
seeking and obtaining
happiness our constitution is is an
incredible document crafted by some
brilliant
men those men would be turning over in
their graves today if they saw what was
going on both with our country as well
abortion I haven't run into anybody so
far who had a child who wished that they
had aborted the child
I have run into some women though who
had an abortion who subsequently said I
didn't make a good choice I wish I knew
now what I knew I wish I knew then what
I know
now the bill is is a step in the right
direction I think it needs to go a lot
further but it's at least a part in
terms of I would I would draw the line
not at six months I would draw the line
a lot further back but at least it
changes the status from where we are
today to to a state that doesn't allow
third trimester abortions perfectly
slaughtered everybody that I've talked
to who had an abortion comes back and
says you know wish I hadn't done that I
miss that
kid when are we going to learn as a
nation that every life is
sacred Constitution is clear there's no
carve outs regarding gestational age
there's no carve outs regarding whether
they're handicapped or not every life
has equal value with that I would ask
you that you would support and pass s SP
399 as sent over from the Senate thank
you thank you for your
testimony that con that uh completes the
number of sign in cards that I have is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
here
today seeing no one I will declare the
hearing on Senate Bill 399 closed
and indicate to the committee that I
obviously misjudged the amount of time
it would take this
morning and we are scheduled for our
next hearing at 10:30 which will give
everybody I think opportunity to get
some coffee so we'll see you all back
10:30
e
good morning
everyone we'll call this meeting of the
house Judiciary Committee back to
order our next item of business this
morning is a hearing on Senate Bill 243
permitting transfer on death Deeds for
real
property the primary sponsor of this
bill is Senator Lou alesandro I see he
is with us this morning and Senator
dandro would you like to introduce your
bill thank you very much uh Mr chairman
it'd be uh an honor and a privilege to
bring this bill uh before one of my
former colleagues uh in in the Senate
and uh a man who's had uh a wonderful
career on the Judiciary so thank you
very much much appreciate that former
Senator good former judge good now
representative good you've got a lot of
titles I come before you as the prime
sponsor of Senate Bill 243 permitting
transfer on death Deeds for real
property this bill would add a whole new
section to our estate laws permitting
the transfer on death of Deeds for Real
Property there are many advantages
including tax advantages but the most
important is avoiding probate
many states already have this
legislation and statute but will be a
new section of law for New Hampshire
here where where is she she's she's just
behind me on on on my left uh it's a
very very simple
Bill uh a beneficiary made this claim
all or part of the beneficiaries in
[Music]
Simplicity it it it we know probate is
problematic uh we we I'm sure all of you
I'm sure many of you have had calls from
constituents about probate and and and
uh going through that particular
situation this makes it much easier it's
it's very simple it's a it's a process
that has been accepted in a number of
states around the country so thank you
sir I appreciate your attention and if
you have any questions that I can answer
I'll try to do it if not others are here
who can address them yeah thank you are
there any questions for Senator
delandro seeing none Senator thank you
for your testimony thank you nice to see
you appreciate always good to see you
thank
Schult hi I'm Barbara schul from gtown
uh thank you for having the hearing and
let me speak on this um
Bill I'm here in full support of Senate
Bill 243 and I hope you will give it
your full support as well it's probably
as L said it's simple it's probably one
of the least controversial bills you'll
have to face this legislative session I
would like to emphasize that Senate Bill
243 received no opposing testimony in
the senate committee hearing and it
passed unanimously through committee and
the full
2021 I hope you will look at SB 243
today with an open mind and a fresh set
of eyes and ears the fact that this
transfer on death deed Bill originated
in both houses of our state legislature
is a strong indicator that the people of
New Hampshire want and need
this hb1 24 the bill you heard in
November was referred to interm study
and I will address the concerns that
arose with regard to that bill later in
my
testimony a transfer on death deed is a
simple inexpensive estate planning tool
not currently available in New Hampshire
it should be noted that 31 states allow
this and I feel it should be allowed
here I am a single person whose Main and
basically only asset is my
home I I have a very small estate other
than my home I want to avoid the very
public timec consuming and expensive
probate process I'm not trying to avoid
taxes I'm not trying to avoid creditors
I'm trying to avoid the very expensive
and public probate process the transfer
on death D that SB 243 that you have
before you now would allow when past
would resolve this issue for me and for
many others in New Hampshire it will
allow me to avoid probate without
incurring legal bills or setting up a
trust which can be a very expensive
process a transfer on death deed is
easy and importantly inexpensive to set
up and it is revocable or
changeable also without Ono expense also
important I will now address the
concerns raised by this committee which
were brought up in
hb24 the summary report of your Comm
Committee Member represent
representative Troy mnz if I'm
pronouncing that correctly mner stated
that the bill was referred for further
study due to unknown effects on the
following three things unknown effect
for banks holding mortgages there is no
effect on banks holding mortgages
transfer on death deed does not avoid
leans it does not avoid creditors it
doesn't do away with any mortgages
there's no
effect another concern was a p proed
procedures at the registry of deeds also
no effect it's no different than
changing a deed for a person's house to
a trust retitling the deed for the trust
retitling the deed for joint with writer
survivorship it's no different it's just
recording a deed very simple um the
other concern was effect on estate pl's
future and current well yes it would
have an effect on future estate plans
because now there would be another
option available to New Hampshire
residents and an inexpensive one
as far as affecting current estate plans
I suppose someone who has already paid
to set up a trust would have the option
of doing this I don't know why they
would um I don't think it would have an
effect on a current estate plan but if
it did it's it's open to someone's
choice to make that
decision um I'm not a lawyer but I'd
like to also emphasize that two of your
colleagues who do have legal expertise
Senator Perkins qura and representative
Barb Griffin are in support of this bill
representative Barbara Griffin had Comm
communicated with me that she was
unfortunately not able to be here today
due to chairing her executive session of
her own house committee the transfer on
death Eed is a useful estate planning
tool that should be available to New
Hampshire residents and it is needed and
supported by same I'm counting on your
support of SP
243 thank you I will take questions if
there are any are there questions for M
missal uh representative
Chase thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question I'm just looking at this
quickly but can you tell me what what
would be considered a h smallest state
like where would the line be
drawn I I don't know that and I'm not a
lawyer um but this transr death deed
would be available to anyone small or
large
representa
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question with respect to
uh the banks holding mortgages in the
other 31 states where this legislation
has been enacted um if property the deed
is transferred is the mortgage just
transferred as well or what's the
mechanism yes the mortgage is not
discharged everything just stays the
same you know the the simplest way to
think about a transfer on death deed is
sort of like a joint with writer
survivorship title where you know if I
had a spouse and the deed would be
titled join of with right of Survivor
and I passed away my spouse would get be
on the deed but with whatever leans
mortgages or anything came with the
property and the transfer and death deed
is is work similarly except it's I would
assume primarily for single people but
not necessarily because again I'm not a
lawyer it's just another tool in the
toolbox that I don't see any reason why
I New Hampshire doesn't have it and I I
did email the committee when this first
came to my attention was in an article
in the union leader and I was all over
it and I said oh my gosh this is exactly
what I need and then come to find out we
didn't have it in New Hampshire hence
why I'm here I don't know why the union
leader ran it without checking first but
in any case that's what brought me here
but there's there's many other resources
I can send to you from you know the uh
different legal sites and so
forth other other questions
from Miss
schul thank you seeing none thank you
for your testimony
kraan
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Susan craigan I am the register
of deeds for marrat County New Hampshire
uh but I am testifying right now on my
own behalf and the reason for that is
that um the
bill the registry of deeds doesn't think
that the bill affects the registry
um something that the Registries as a
whole should test should testify about
however uh when we were discussing it we
noticed one particular section that we
thought might cause problems and that's
why I'm testifying in opposition and
only to this one section and that is 563
d10 notice delivery acceptance and
consideration are not
required um so what does this
mean this means that ownership can be
thrust upon perhaps an unwilling
recipient and let me tell you a little
bit about what happened to me recently
and this was just in the context of a
will not in the context of this type of
deed my husband was bequeathed by will
one quarter of a house when his mother
died and he immediately disclaimed the
gift which he was entitled to do because
it was a will and probate why because he
didn't want the property and there were
good reasons for
it there were environmental hazards that
my husband had notice of the water
wasn't pable there was black mold in the
basement decades old fur treat grew
within a couple of feet of the house one
of which could crush the tiny house in
the right wind the wood pile had been
kept too close to the house and there
was bug
infestation two there were obligations
that ran with the land that he didn't
want to take on including partial
responsibility for keeping a water
course clear three he thought a creditor
lean might exceed the real value of the
property he had cash that the bank could
go after in a deficiency judge
ment four ownership would be partial
among four siblings three of whom wanted
to keep the house for sentimental
reasons one of these we suspected was
insolvent and knew was irresponsible
with money and a second mentioned using
it as a weekend retreat for a religious
group we
disliked and those were the two siblings
he got along
with if my husband had not disclaimed
claimed under the will he would have had
to take time to go to New York State get
a lawyer to arrange the transfer with
expenses and
headaches
um the American Association of retired
persons thinks there are good reasons to
decline a bequest of real property it's
a good tax move for instance if the
property would then go to your child who
has a lower tax consequence it's a dog a
property property taxes can eat up um
unpaid property taxes environmental risk
and other
reasons three it will trigger a
government Aid eligibility
review uh for instance in medic for
Medicaid you can't have more than $2,000
in assets suppose you give this property
to my mother who's in a nursing home and
who Medicaid is paying for but if she
has more than $2,000 of assets they will
stop
um four it will trigger a family drama
and this is important in New Hampshire
because a lot of these properties are
likely to be summer cottages things with
memories five it will go to your
creditors are you on the brink of
bankruptcy do you really care if you get
one more small
asset and six it's the right thing to
do now suppose that in addition to all
this the beneficiary does not get notice
of the death of or of the transfer
property to himself right away suppose
before I die suppose it's me doing it I
execute a transfer on death Deed on a
toxic dump to a person I don't know but
despise or who's difficult to locate
what happens
then um
and I'm sure that towns always want to
bills that's one major problem with this
bill that there's no notice and there's
no
acceptance um and it becomes a big
problem for the recipients
sometimes and for their for that reason
and that reason alone
I am testifying in opposition for this
to this bill as written I think that
there should be a requirement for notice
and acceptance on the deed
itself any
questions are there questions for Miss
craigan yes representative Simpson thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm going to pref preface this
with that I am not oh sorry I'm going to
take the off um I am not a lawyer so I
everybody else might understand this but
so when it says notice or delivery
without notice or delivery to or
acceptance by the designated beneficiary
during the transfer's life does that
mean that the person who has deeded
the land uh can decline the transfer
after the transfer has died
or oh will you go to the microphone
because I other people may have the same
not see that's the problem there is a
period where property ownership is
ambiguous and I think that ambigu
ambiguity is not a good
thing um
so
your you don't need
owners
here's the problem no matter how
small that transfer period is there's
still a there's still a a a Time point
in time where the ownership of the land
unknown so let's say
um let's say my neighbor across the
street Wills me her
house um after having um and then leaves
me a letter saying that she hopes that
I'll take care of her son or something
like that um if I get the
property no that's a bad actually that's
um
you if I there's no provision in there
that requires notice to be given to me
and then requires me to accept it okay
now if
apparently there's a the possibility
that I can turn it down at some point in
the future once I get notice of the
transfer but suppose I don't get notice
right away how long does that happen how
long does that take and let's suppose
that I start telling people that I just
got notice after I found out there's
toxic waste on there then it becomes a
question of fact for the court probably
but it could lead to messy litigation
and what I'm saying is that this bill
could be made dramatically better by the
addition of a notice requirement and a
and a line on that deed that says that
the recipient agrees to the
transfer and I don't think that's a big
ask
and the other thing is too I I
complained about this bill to the
uniform law commission which drafted
it and I got a letter back from the
draft
door that
was um that didn't address the point he
didn't understand
why
um definite ownership of property
is is a an important thing and can be a
problem and I don't think also I mean I
think everybody's taking it from the
point of view of the person who has the
estate the person who wants to give away
um their small landh holding to a
descendant and that's a fine thing to do
I have no problem with that at all um
but you have to consider all the
ramifications of this
bill okay are there other questions
representative
Chase thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm just again I'm
not a lawyer either and I want to try to
clarify so right now if somebody has a
deed on a property
um they don't have to write a little
note saying this is where I want the
property to go so you're that say I
passed away and I had left a note in my
dresser drawer that my property was to
go to my son is that the way things go
now I'm just trying to figure out is
that what you're talking about with
property if it's not on the deed and
writing that little bit of a couple of
lines you just have to wait until
up exactly according to this bill the
only paper you need is the deed
itself and then you file the deed with
the registry of
deeds and
then that's all you need is that one
piece of
paper so you know if the piece of paper
is lost let's
say then who knows um you know how do
you find out where that property has
gone
other questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um the the
bill does allow you to uh disclaim the
the benefit but the language on page two
does explicitly state that a transfer on
death deed is effective without notice
or delivery and it's actually not an
Omission but it's explicit in here that
you do not have to to have um a notice
of delivery or acceptance so
unfortunately the prime sponsor is not
here do you know why that explicit
bill I have no idea I have asked the
other registries of
deeds and um we have no idea it doesn't
make any logical sense to me and I think
it's
incorrect
oh follow up are are you aware in the
other 31 states that were referenced if
they have other explicit because this
it's a very explicit provision you're
right that says acceptance
doesn't notice or delivery to the or
acceptance by the designated beneficiary
during the transfer life is not required
so it is explicit do you know do the
other states have that as well I don't
know about the other states um but it is
possible that in addition to having
passed the bill um there are other
requirements somehow um or that the bill
has been added on to saying that if the
property isn't claimed within a certain
amount it reverts back here's the
problem with listening to the pro the um
uniform law
commission if they if you pass their
bill they say it's passed whether you
edit it or not and I don't know if any
of the states have edited it or added on
to it or if there's another superseding
law that adds requirements to it so I
don't know that but I do know that
looking at a chart that says that 31
States passed the bill um isn't doesn't
give you all the information that's
number one number two um states have a
tendency to pass uniform law commission
laws without reading them
carefully um
and that happened recently with the um
online notarization bill and we passed
that bill and we thought it was fine um
and it's been revised and now the
uniform law commission says that the law
we just passed isn't good enough and we
should re we should pass another one
this year
so um the uniform law
Commissioners have good ideas but
they're human and they make
mistakes um and they go back and revise
their own
questions thank you for your testimony
today you're
puck
good morning uh my name is Kelly o Puck
I'm a real estate attorney here in
conquered I'm testifying in opposition
to this bill and I'm testifying on my
own behalf I'm not testifying on behalf
of anyone else
um I think the regist pointed out what
the main issue here with this bill is it
offers elery Simplicity which can be a
very dangerous thing um especially for
Lay people who don't may not understand
the implications of what they're doing
um someone could go out and prepare this
deed and have it noiz thinking this is a
very simple solution to a problem and
not fully understand the ramifications
the transfer property is
complicated real estate is often the
most important the most valuable asset
somebody has and it is serious and it
can have ramifications that are serious
and um so I think we need to understand
that while this may look like a simple
solution it's not that simple and it may
actually create more problems than it
solves um one of the main problems has
already been discussed and pointed out
which is this notice issue so the fact
that whoever is the named beneficiary
isn't required to accept the deed isn't
required to be notified um isn't
required to be somebody who is related
or alive or you know of age so all of
these things create uncertainty create
risk um as to the question about
disclaimer so there is a disclaimer
provision in the proposed statute um it
allows the beneficiary to disclaim
within 60 days of the transfer's
death so the problem with this is what
if there's a beneficiary who doesn't
know about the transfer death there's no
provision in here that requires any
notice to the registry to the town of
the transfer death so we do have this
huge
uncertainty that's built in when
somebody passes away and they've
executed one of these deeds and
frankly I think it creates a burden on
the
registers and on the towns to try and
figure out who these beneficiaries are
where they are located if they're still
alive if they're not alive what happens
um we do have appropriate process for a
reason it provides order it provides
notice we have rules um and it provides
opportunity for people to understand the
process and have the process of transfer
of property which is very important and
serious um be taken
seriously in addition I'd like to point
out we already do have a process to to
transfer property without going through
probate and it's through the creation of
a trust um which often does require
going to an attorney and getting advice
of counsel but that's appropriate and it
doesn't have to be super
expensive um I think there there are
some other attorneys who will be
testifying a little bit more about that
I'm I kind of practice on the real
estate side of things so I'm more
focused on how it affects title how it
might affect creditors another thing
that I want to point out about um the
uncertainty and the risk with title of
not knowing what the status of title is
and who the owner is is that there's a
there's an 18month period in the statute
that the property will still be subject
to claims of the state so that means
there's an 18month period where we don't
know for sure is this property going to
be subject to these claims that makes it
very likely that whoever is the
beneficiary is not going to be able to
do anything with this property during
that 18-month period without opening a
probate
anyway so um it's unlikely that any
lender is going to lend money that's
secured by that property it's unlikely
that any title insurer is going to Ure
title to that property during that
period and then we have this whole
period where um that beneficiary could
go out and transfer the property and
then it may still be subject to
creditors claims and we have to un Trel
all of that it could be very messy um it
just creates a lot of risk of confusion
and uncertainty that I think isn't
really apparent with what seems like a
idea um the another um defect that I
would like the committee to consider
about this statute is that it doesn't
offer a whole lot of guidance there are
no forms attached it talks about the
possibility not only the transfer of
death uh on death deed but it also talks
about re an instrument of
revocation um there's no forms provided
for that so again we're not offering the
kind of guidance that we need to provide
to both people who want to take
advantage of this but also others title
insurers creditors third other third
parties who may have interest in this
property are the forms sufficient is
what's been done
adequate um so that's another def that I
think really needs to be looked at
before this bill um is seriously
passage I think that's the bulk of what
I'd like to say um again I am a real
estate attorney and I'm happy to take
any
questions any
questions representative wer first uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question would you spell your
name for me please certainly it's O VI
Victor i t as and Tom another T as and
Tom space p as and Peter U as an
Puck okay are you all set no but I'll
I'll talk to her
after I I think I know I can give that
representative mlan did you have a
question yes thank you um I'm sensitive
to the testimony um about the the notice
and acceptance and on the disclaimer
side but I just I am just trying to
reconcile in my mind why the bill put in
explicit language saying that uh
notification is not required so are you
aware of any reason why that kind of
language would have been put in the bill
I know you're not the prime sponsor but
well this is just speculation but it
does give more flexibility for people
who want to do this and don't
necessarily want to notify the
beneficiaries or track them down um
that's that's you know and maybe some of
the other um other people who will test
if I have a better idea but that's
that's the only Insight I have to offer
flexibility other questions
question thank you thank you for taking
my question again I'm just trying to
wrap my head around the the landh
holding because one person said there
wasn't a it could be a large land
holding or or or small and then the last
person who testified from um mayor
mcdeed said it she was talking about
small landh Holdings what how large of
an estate are we talking about that
someone can just leave the property to
somebody my my understanding is that
this this would apply no matter the size
of the state that you could use a
transfer of death deed regardless of the
state other
questions typically in a real estate
transfer if you just do a
deed uh there is paperwork associated
with that which
would notify the federal government but
notify the towns of the
transfer and it appears that that's not
required as a part of this if you if if
you're not notifying the if you're not
notifying the recipient potential
recipient of the
property how can you I guess the
question is how can you properly notify
the
town I I agree I think that's an issue
so so when the deed is recorded there
will be notice it will be recorded at
the registry and there will be notice
but there's no notice required to the
beneficiary there's no kind of
validating the beneficiary is somebody
who actually exists who is alive who
there they have a valid address all of
that and there's no notice required to
the beneficiary there's also no notice
um that the actual effectiveness of the
transfer is triggered by the transfer's
death and there's no notice required for
that so that's a Hu that's a huge gap
no you you can't so
you okay thank you can I make one final
comment um and I should have said this
before a lot of statutes are
interrelated and so one thing that I
would urge this committee to consider is
if they they are going to support this
bill please look at the other statutes
that may be affected by this so for
example what happens if the transferer
names their spouse and they get divorced
does that you know we have statutes that
relate to that um that we have a real
estate transfer tax does that apply here
um so I think it's crucial that if this
bill is passed we think about all of the
other statutes that may be impacted
which have been carefully crafted um in
light of our intesity scheme in light of
our um our probate Statute in that
process so thank you for your time today
salik Miss craigan perhaps at the end
we'll give you an opportunity to testify
again but we let everybody have an
opportunity to testify
first you thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Elise s
and I'm an attorney at Solway and Hollis
here in conquer and I am an estate
planner uh that is what I do and what
I've done for the past 30 years and I'm
here speaking on my own behalf in
opposition to SB
243 and I do have some background for
the committee on our statute and how it
compares to the statutes that have been
passed in the other jurisdictions so
just by way of background I think the
committee should be aware that I I think
it's 29 states in the district of
Colombia not 31 states have some form of
transfer on death deed legislation on
the
books of those
jurisdictions
19 have statutes that are based on the
uniform real property transfer on death
act and that is the act that was used as
the model for the statute that's forms
the basis of
b243 but the problem with our statute
it's one of many problems from my
perspective is that if you take a look
at the uniform real property transfer on
death act and you compare it to the
words that are contained in s SP
243 we're missing a third of the
statutory language so the sponsor the
drafters of this statute basically went
so far and then stopped and that's
what's creating some of the title issues
and some of the concerns that have been
raised by Miss kraan and by my colleague
Kelly oit Puck but just to back up a
little bit um there are a lot of issues
with this statute I'm not here to say
that New Hampshire should not have a
transfer on death deed statute I think
we should I think it would be a valuable
tool not just in my toolbox as an estate
planner but also in the toolbox of lay
people who are looking for a simple way
to transfer property so I don't have a
philosophical issue with SB
243 I just think the statute is
deficient and needs some
improvement and by way of improvement
I'm going to point to one issue that I
see a lot in my practice because I also
do probate litigation and that issue is
undue influence I have a big concern
about the elderly population here in New
Hampshire being unduly influenced to
transfer property to their relatives or
their friends this is an issue that we
see every day and if you take a look at
the California version of this statute
you know I rarely look to California as
a model of much but in this instance I
think California got it right because
what California did about five years ago
is they passed their first transfer on
death deed statute and they built a
sunset provision in it a fiveyear sunset
for the explicit purpose of looking back
five years into having transfer on death
Deeds to identify any problems or issues
that had Arisen during that 5year period
that then needed to be corrected and one
of the biggest issues that happened in
California is fraud and undoin for
so in January of 2021 when the
California legislature looked at its
transfer on death deed statute after its
initial implementation period of 5 years
the first thing that they tweet was were
the requirements for signing a valid
transfer on death deed if you take a
look at the language of SB
243 right now in order to sign one of
these transfer on death Deeds you need
the same capacity that you would have to
make a will and I think that's a good
thing but there are no other
requirements and right now in order to
sign a deed here in New Hampshire you
just have to put your name on the deed
in the presence of a notary there are no
witness
requirements and what California has
done is they've now added a provision to
their statute to try to protect against
fraud and undo influence by now
requiring that transfer on death Deeds
be accompanied
by two witnesses and they've built a
presumption into their statute that says
that if the Witnesses are also the
beneficiaries of the property their
transactions presumptively invalid so I
think if we're going to make an attempt
to introduce or have a transfer on death
Statute in New Hampshire we need to
tackle the issue of un influence and we
need to look to California and some of
the other states that have had this
legislation for a while and maybe think
about adding w witness requirements on
these deeds and from my perspective as
an estate planner these Deeds are
revocable which is a wonderful thing you
can you should be able to change your
mind about the people you've named in
your transfer on death deed but if
you're going to be able to revoke your
deed then you should have you you should
be able to revoke it under the same
legal standards that too should require
Witnesses and so there that issue is not
addressed at all in SB 243 and I really
think it needs to
be another issue is the issue of
contingent beneficiaries and this is
something that Miss craigan touched on
what happens if you leave your property
in a transfer on death deed to your two
children and one of them pred deases you
they're just not alive to take the
property under the current statute
that's before you at SB
243 the deceased child's interest
lapses so basically the property goes
100% to your surviving
child as an estate planner I can tell
you that in my practice parents don't do
that what parents like to say in their
wills and in their trusts is that if a
child
predeceases the deceased child's
interest passes down the line to
grandchildren or to great-grandchildren
there's no opportunity in Sp 243 to do
that and in some of the more well
crafted transfer on death deed statutes
there is the ability to name contingent
beneficiaries the interest of a deceased
beneficiary doesn't just lapse so again
my position is that if you're going to
do this we should do this right and we
should give the members of of the public
here in New Hampshire an opportunity to
name contingent beneficiaries in their
deeds I think that's an important
planning
tool
I also have some concerns about
electronic signatures um we have an
electronic signature act in New
Hampshire you are currently allowed to
sign a deed electronically but there's
no mention in s SP 243 as to whether
transfer on death Deeds also are subject
to electronic signature requirements and
as Kelly said there are a lot there's a
lot of interplay between real estate
transactions and other statutes and so
the electronic signatures act really
needs to be looked at and woven into the
fabric of our transfer on death deed
legislation if we're going to go this
route my other issue and this is not
addressed at all in Sp 243 is what about
Powers of
Attorney if you're
incapacitated and you're and you're
you've got a durable power attorney one
of your kids is paying your bills and
taking care of all of your financial
affairs do we think it's appropriate as
a matter of public policy to allow
agents under durable Powers of Attorney
to sign a transfer on death deed I don't
know the answer to that question but I
know in a lot of the states that have
enacted this kind of legislation there
is specific mention in their statute
that either permits an agent under a
power of attorney to sign one of these
Deeds on behalf of someone who's
incapacitated or there's an
explicit reference in the statute that
says you can't allow an agent to sign
one of these Deeds I think that issue
should also be addressed and if we do
want to address this issue we're going
to have to take a look at our dpoa
statute and we're going to need to make
some changes to the durable power of
attorney act to create the powers needed
to sign one of these transfer on death
Deeds on behalf of an in capacitated
individual I'm not saying it's a bad
idea I again I think that would be a
useful tool but we've got to look at
multiple statutes if we want to go that
route my final comment has to do with
contesting a transfer on death
deed if there has been fraud or undue
influence in the in the execution of one
of these Deeds there needs to be a
provision in our statute that permits
people to contest that deed and again in
most of the well-crafted statutes that
I've seen those Provisions do exist so
you know in in wrapup my my concerns are
that our statute is deficient in that it
does not contain all of the language
that the model act
contains there are 30 other
jurisdictions out there that have done
this before and if we take a look at
their statutes and incorporate the best
of what's out there I think we will have
a very good piece of legislation but I
don't think we're there
yet thank you other
questions uh yes representative
mner yes and the last piece on uh
contestants so that would be kicked to
probate well that's a good question um
typically when you're contesting a will
or a conveyance that takes effect at
death the Circuit Court probate division
does have jurisdiction over those claims
but there's nothing in the statute that
says that and so I
suspect those claims could be brought
in Superior Court I I have no idea and
so the jurisdictional issue does need to
be addressed I to me it makes logical
sense if you're going to allow a contest
to have that contest heard in the C
Circuit Court probate division but again
that's an issue of public policy and it
should be addressed in the
statute other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today
[Music]
nerk thank you chairman thank you
members of the committee uh Pam Newkirk
NE w k iir k
um I'm also an attorney um I practice in
Bedford New Hampshire um at a law firm
barale o c new Kirk and dwire I'm here
today testifying on my own
behalf um and um I am in opposition to
the bill as
written um my practice is limited to
probate
litigation um and messy probate issues
um sometimes that AR full born
full-blown litigation but often times um
I deal with issues that arise with
problems with statutory construction and
that sort of
thing um I I wanted to testify a little
bit about disclaimer but I think that um
issue has been very thoroughly covered
by all those who have spoken before me
um I I I just um want to reiterate
however that I think that if as written
this would be the only type of gift that
could be made without the consent of the
gift recipient I think every other um
type of gift that is made um has to be
accepted and our disclaimer statute
acknowledges that and allows without any
time limitation a person to disclaim a
gift um whether it's during a life made
during the lifetime or upon death um
just provided that they have not already
exercised IND of ownership of the
property I think that there's a um
problem as attorney salic um very um you
know considerately addressed with
pulling out pieces of a uniform body of
law that um you know don't don't include
all the necessary
components the other issue is there may
be a
uniform um act concerning this type of
transfer but in most of the states that
have adopted such a thing they've
Incorporated with it with all the other
uniform bodies of law so that even
though it's talking about real estate
transfers it makes reference to probate
terms that are defined in that state
uniform probate code which is something
we don't have here in New
Hampshire and when when those terms are
pulled pulled in it may may may make
sense to lay people but then lawyers get
to deal with them in court afterwards
and they're trying to figure out what
that specific term means when it's part
of a defined body of law that we have
not
adopted so having said that um I think
that there's a um General problem with
the statute that a lot of the deadlines
that are included are triggered by the
date of death and just for edification
purposes probate law is not triggered by
date of death probate law is triggered
by the date that probate is opened and
in fact most deadlines in Probate are
defined by the date the administrator is
appointed by the court which may be very
far from the date that the probate the
will and the petition to open probate
are
filed so um having said those General
things I'd like to talk specifically
about the Creditor section of the
statute and I have had some experience
with um the problems in our current
statutory scheme concerning trust
property that's available to pay
creditors of an
estate and the New Hampshire probate
statutes has a very
Express um and
clear mechanism for how creditors claims
get filed and
paid upon the appointment of the
administrator the creditors have 6
months from the date of the appointment
of the administrator to file a claim
with the court and then in the second
six months if the Creditor has some
Communications with the executive of the
estate about getting paid and it appears
that the executive does not intend to
pay those things then the Creditor has
to bring a lawsuit against the estate
within that second six-month period of
time
and um and and see if their claim is
legally viable and if it is then the
executive has to or the administrator
has to pay that
claim
um here we're talking about creditor's
claims being paid within 18 months after
the date of death there's no
guarantee that you're going to have an
estate open and that you're going to
know what all the creditors claims are
within that 18th month period it is
possible um that it wouldn't happen
until after that sometimes people delay
opening probate because of the grieving
process um there's all sorts of things
that can happen sometimes there are
fights over who is going to be the
executive of the estate and and that
requires uh you know litigation our
courts are already so overburdened that
they cannot handle those things always
within a you know what to The Grieving
parties would think is a reasonable
period of time um
so that that's a timing process with
regard to the claim there's a reference
in um 563
D15 to the payment of an allowed
claim of an estate there's no such thing
in our estate process of allowed claims
unless you have an insolvent estate that
you that you've got administered and
then there's a whole insolvency process
but that's not referred to here they
just talk about an allowed
claim it's not clear to me that a um if
there are assets in someone's trust that
are available to pay the debts of an
estate that you have to go through the
whole insolvency process um which is you
know complicated and more costly it's
easier just to call them in because
they're required to be called in under
law um having said that I'll get to the
problem that I had before so I had a
decedent who had an estate he also had a
trust his trust owned a business the
business had very specific debts that it
owed after the guy
died the trustee paid the debts of the
trust paid started to gather information
about the estate come to find out that
deedan hadn't paid his income taxes for
years and his estate was
insolvent so they had to call in the
assets of his
trust well the statutory scheme that we
have now and there is a statute that
says the debts of a decedent
are properly can be paid out or they're
subject to that the trust is subject to
pay claims of the estate for which the
assets are
insufficient it doesn't say that the
debts and the assets of the trust are
basically treated as a whole with the
estate and that everything gets paid
prata that is how the judge treated it
in the case I had I don't know that
that's clear under the law and in
another case we might have gone up
before The Supreme Court we did not do
with that on the one that we have here
now we're adding with this statute
another layer where you're talking about
this deed that transfers property upon
death can be subject to claims of
creditors well what priority is it prata
with the assets of the estate that it
would be applied do you have to use up
all the assets of the estate and then
you go to the trust first and then to
the deeded property or how how does all
that work that is not part of this and I
think that at some point that's probably
going to come
up um there are
references um
in the statute I think it's um section
to
um it's and it's paragraph one so 563
D13 paragraph 1 it says as except as
otherwise provided in the transfer on
death
deed um or in statutes governing
anti-lapse revocation by divorce or
homicide survival and simultaneous death
and elective share if applicable to
nonprobate
transfers I'm unaware of any of those
things being applicable to nonprobate
transfers as our laws currently stand
and I would suggest that it not be in
there if it's not applicable right now
um because you're just creating I think
a suggestions confusion to some people
that maybe there's um some opening there
to make hey about those
things
um the Creditor section also says that
the
State
enforces the claims against the property
well if you've got as the very nice lady
from Goffstown testified earlier a
single asset you've got no probate
you're doing this to avoid probate who's
the estate who's going to enforce that
who's going to open that up is the
Creditor going to open that up and then
the Creditor is going to charge all
kinds of charges to open up the probate
and to find people and that's going to
be a costly
thing
um there's also a reference in the
Creditor section to an
allowance um to a surviving spouse or
child we don't we have those perhaps in
under
intestacy but there's an elective share
that a wife can make um against a will
um and you know if the person has a will
but they just didn't have any assets to
probate how does that all how does that
all play out um that's not clear and
it's pretty mucked up in the way the
statute's
written um the last thing is under the
Creditor statutes that we have for
Estates we have um it's a um common law
as um identified by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court that we all follow um and
it comes follows a new uh US Supreme
Court case um and it was something
versus Tulsa we call them Tulsa notices
so the normal statute limitations for
creditors claims is to make those claims
within 3 years under our probate
statutes as as I discussed earlier we
have a short claims period you have to
know you have to file the claim with the
probate within 6 months of the
administrator's appointment and then you
have to pursue litigation on your claim
Within the following six months if you
want to be guaranteed that you're going
to get
paid we have to send out notices to the
creditors to let them know of this short
claim statute there's no notice
Provisions here to notify creditors of
this and I could foresee a creditor
saying well I didn't know within the 18
months and therefore I get to have an
exception here because you've otherwise
changed my constitutionally allowed time
period in order to bring a claim on the
default
debt um I think that's all I have for
today and I'm perfectly happy to work
with anyone on integrating this because
I you know I I don't oppose the um
concept but I just think that we're
probably creating a bunch of problems
unless this gets cleaned up before it
goes for a full vote thank you for your
testimony questions representative Chase
did you have a question thank you thank
you for taking my question I'm just
curious in the beginning of this the the
testimony or it was just said there was
no opposing in this past unanimously
through the
Senate did you testify in front of the
senate or any of these other issues were
they brought up I I did not um I so I
found out about this because um there
are a bunch of us um who practice trust
in estate law um who have a committee
and we keep try to keep track of
legislation and sometimes we don't
always find out about it when it first
comes up but we did find out about it
and discussed it and came up
today representative
Horgan thank you very much um you
mentioned the issue of probate being
open and I noticed there's a case of
well there's a former State rain Andrew
Z from from Hampton was her name who
died believe in September and I went to
her funeral and then I was
surprised uh over 6 months later that
the notice was just being now put out by
uh the probate clerk so is that a
unusually is that a um longer than you
than typical La for those notices in the
newspaper or is that shorter or it
certainly is a significant amount of
time after after her passing I'm I'm
sorry I was having something yeah you
might want to take your mask off to just
speak into the mic so that you can be
understood
thank you I just happen to notice U you
know the one of the processes in Probate
is uh they put a notices in the
newspaper typically in the back pages of
the of the union leader here in New
Hampshire so I noticed just uh a former
colleague of mine who died over six
months ago her notice was just published
a few days ago so is that a uh and
that's a signific amount of time so that
is that um is that about uh is that
about average for uh the gap between
when the person dies and when the uh
probate process is opened or is it
usually shorter or perhaps even
longer it it can be shorter longer um it
just you know grief is difficult and it
is individual and um you know sometimes
there's a need to open it up quickly
sometimes people want to get it done and
over with sometimes people are so pained
that they want to put it off it it
really is depend you know I think most
people get to it pretty quickly um but
it really depends on the
individual thank you you have a followup
yes and I guess the purpose of those
notices is um just in case one of the
purpos notices is just in case um a
deceased person owes you money you at
least have a theoretical chance of
seeing in the newspaper and being able
to file a claim so uh would there be is
that was it would it would you be losing
that protection if uh we if the if we if
we uh adopted this transfer and deed act
as
is I I don't know that there are
creditors who peruse the notices that
are filed by the probate courts to see
who has died I I just I don't think that
that is sufficient notice to a creditor
to require them to be bound by that
statute thank you thank you any other
questions not thank you for testifying
today that is all the cards I
have is there anyone else who wishes to
testify seeing none we will close the
hearing on Senate Bill 243 and thank
everyone who appeared here today to
testify and we will move move directly
on to our next
344 primary sponsor of Senate Bill 344
is Senator Daniels and Senator Daniels
bill
I'm sorry we're running a little later
than we expected Senator
Daniels but having waited two and a half
hours from my hearing in the Senate the
other day I'm not feeling very sorry
so we probably owe you a little bit I'll
do what I can to try to get you back on
track thank you for the record my name
is Gary Daniels I'm state senator for
District 11 encompassing the towns of
Wilton Milford amest and marac I'm also
the sponsor of Senate bill
344 which has has to do with uh virtual
meetings I think we we do what we can uh
in these Chambers to gain more
participation in public affairs uh
Senate Bill 344 is an invitation to the
public to better know what goes on in
the political subdivisions of the state
it does not pertain to the general court
first and foremost this bill is enabling
legislation
something this body has historically
supported it enables the legislative
body to decide whether or not they wish
to allow their governing boards to meet
virtually with the stipulation that
there must be at least a quarter of the
governing board physically present at a
specified location open to the
public it's an Undisputed fact that over
the past couple years the use of virtual
meetings has increased public
participation ation in local meetings
given greater opportunity for the public
to watch their elected officials perform
their duties and interactively
communicate with them last year we
passed House Bill
108 that bill authorized virtual
meetings but there was later changed to
a study
committee out of that study committee
came a number of references that are
built into this this bill before you and
including that a physical location
remain a
requirement that a minimum of a quarter
of the board shall be physically present
at that
location that remote participation for
members should be allowed in
non-emergency
situations with
restraint that the quote not reasonably
practical standard for remote
participation with Doc documenting such
reason in the minutes should
remain that all votes taken in a virtual
meeting shall be by roll call
vote that instructions on how the public
can access the meeting be included in
the meeting notice along with the means
by which the public can notify the body
if transmission to the public is
interrupted and that in the event of
interruption the meeting shall be
adjourned until the public is able to
access the meeting
these record these recommendations are
contained with with the bill along with
the additional requirement that a
virtually participating member must have
his or her camera actively displaying
the member's
face it's time that we let the local
community decide whether or not they
consider virtual meetings beneficial in
understanding how their local government
operates and to that regard I
respectfully ask that you support
support this enabling legislation and
vote Senate Bill 344 ought to pass thank
you Mr chairman thank you are there
senator saying none thanks for your
testimony today thank you nice to see
you
quoka I promise not to shut you down
today so good morning everyone um nice
to see you
so uh I am rising in support of SB 344 I
had a digital meetings bill as well SP
322 and Senator Daniels and I decided to
combine our bills and work together on
this version um that is in front of you
today as we all saw firsthand during the
end of the 2020 legislative session in
the entirety of
2021 remote access to meetings provides
a wealth of benefits more people can
participate in hearings and have their
voices heard people with differing
abilities and health are ensured access
without concern and more elected
officials can be the voice that their
constituents elected them to be without
worry worrying that employment Child
Care Transportation will simply be a bar
to them holding office towns can save
Administration and staff cost and better
serve their residents it's a local
control issue as well I've worked very
closely with my friends from districts
10 and 11 to craft an amendment that
will Empower local communities to vote
to allow digital meetings as passed by
the Senate this bill leaves 91a
completely intact as it exists today and
then simply adds a new section on the
end which allows a vote by the
legislative body of municipalities to
expand access to remote
meetings as Senator Daniels mentioned
there are some parameters around how a
municipality can expand and local
meetings including having a quarter of
the board physically present um making
sure that if the public is unable to
access the meeting due to a problem with
the host that the meeting is adjourned
until that access is restored and that
all meetings held remotely must display
a member's face and and take a roll call
vote however it will provide an option
to municipalities to ensure that we're
not forcing digital or remote meetings
in situations where municipalities may
not want them but we're also allowing
them for communities where this makes
sense and where it can encourage
diversity of participation um by members
of our public
bodies it is our opinion here in the
Senate that this issue does not need
further study that we've all lived
through this experience to great success
and we'd love to enable our towns and
cities to
continue thank you Mr chairman I'm happy
to take any questions are there
questions for the senator yes
representative wper uh thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh the Bill calls for a quarter
of the total membership to be present at
the physical location does that have any
relationship to the Quorum
requirement it does not the Quorum
requirement can still be set pursuant to
local
followup remote participation
participants shall have their video
on
does that mean that in areas without
good Broadband they can't conduct remote
meetings so I think it's something that
municipalities will have to consider but
in the Senate um the discussion was that
we want to ensure that if remote
meetings are to continue that they are
always in the spirit that you know we we
do the best discussing when we can see
each other when we can talk and make eye
contact that our elected officials are
available to us and so that was a a
bipartisan compromise to make sure that
this bill you know reflected as um a
broad opinion as we
could and a followup so
you the bill requires that if there are
problems with electronic access that the
meeting be
postponed won't that create substantial
difficulties for the board or whatever
that's meeting in terms of scheduling
meeting
deadlines um again this is purely adding
an option so it's a choice by
municipality to
say you know we think that this remote
style of meeting and and making it
available is important to us enough that
we can accommodate um you know sort of
the public notice and Public Access
aspects of it so in our mind um we
limited to that adjournment to when
there are problems with the host or the
broadcaster it it surely does not
include um I can't get my zoom to work
so uh you know we wanted to to make sure
that it's it's in a limited situation
but that you know the public being able
piece we all set yep and there are there
other questions for the senator
representative mlan just a quick
question Senator with respect to scope
a political subdivision that doesn't
bind the that go to the legislature as
well or if that's not legislature that's
just cities towns boards Etc that's
right thank you for the clarification
representative representative so there
is a specific line in there just to
avoid any ambiguity that this bill does
not apply to the general court it is
simply towns cities counties and other
I think prompted mostly by the community
power Coalition of their ability to to
use this bill um to hold remote meetings
and so to do that um we would need an
amendment to the current language to
include instrumentalities created under
RSA 53a um which I'm happy to talk to
you further about but just to answer
your specific question it does not apply
to the general
court thank you other question questions
representative
Horgan yes the way I read this this
seems to put put an end to a practice
which was uh not well somewhat common
long before the pandemic came along and
we started having Zoom meetings and uh
which was occasionally you would have a
member participating in a uh
participating in the hearing by uh by
speaker phone so that would no
longer um that would no longer be
allowed if this bill passes since the
speaker phone doesn't show the picture
of the person who's speaking it's a very
good question representative so
um I am not here to provide legal advice
on it the existing
91a would remain intact exactly as it is
if a municipality voted through its
legislative body under this new section
to expand the use of digital meetings um
then pursuant to that section it would
questions seeing none thank you Senator
thank you very
much I do have a card from Senator
Apprentice in support of the bill is she
here don't see
Hill
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is Karen Leo Hill
I am the Grafton County Treasurer um but
more importantly for the purposes today
I'm an 18-year city counselor from the
city of Lebanon I am here um because
over the past 18 years I have seen the
with can you hear me
better
okay my name is Karen Leo Hill I'm an
18-year City councelor in the city of
Lebanon and happy to be with you today
and in support of SB
344 over 18 years I have certainly seen
the struggles that we have with uh
participation in public meetings and it
has been one of the Silver Linings over
the last two years that remote meetings
have enabled more people to participate
at more frequently and I believe that
actually our democracy has been
strengthened because technology has been
deployed in such a successful way I
believe that s SP
344 is truly a path forward that will
allow this greater level of
participation while safeguarding our
democracy things that are important to
us deliberation the ability to engage
with one another about different issues
as a member of the city council over the
last two years I have observed firsthand
that we have been able to Grapple with
discussions with issues even sometimes
very controversial issues such as a
proposal to um to uh defund the police
department by 50% so we have engaged in
some very tense controversial
discussions we have been able to have
that deliberation that was important to
truly reflect what the people of Lebanon
wanted and to be able to make decisions
that represented many
voices so we've been able to have
deliberation I can recall back I'll make
this very um practical I can recall back
16 years ago when I was pregnant with my
younger child and there were times when
at the end of a long day I was just too
tired my ankles were too too swollen to
sit through a three or a 4-Hour city
council meeting and unfortunately I had
to make the choice sometimes to stay
home having the ability to participate
remotely would have benefited me and I
believe would have been would have
benefited the constituents who elected
me and I would have if this legislation
had been in place at the time and the
technology had been in place at the time
which I don't know if it was uh I would
have been able to continue in the the
public service that I had been elected
to do um while attending to my health
concerns I think the same would apply to
people recovering from knee replacement
surgery or um hip replacement surgery
for example as well and so in summary I
would just ask that you consider
supporting this legislation I believe
that it is good for democracy it is good
for public participation it is good for
public service
while also safeguarding the most
important parts uh and traditions of New
Hampshire democracy being
deliberation as well as having a
physical space where a member of the
public can come if they are not able or
interested in participating remotely so
by having the physical presence that is
an important Safeguard by having
the uh the the only issue I would say is
the video on I think until we truly have
Broadband ubiquitous Broadband in the
state sometimes you have to keep your
video off to maintain the connection so
if if anyone was open to an amendment I
might consider that would be the only
area that I think an amendment might be
prudent um but overall I think this is a
bill that safeguards democracy honors
the best of our Traditions here in New
Hampshire but does move forward uh in
allowing Tech techology to support us in
our efforts thank you very much are
there questions from Miss
Hill representative mlan thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question just in in your experience you
know being a part of meetings for 18
years um the the legislation says that
you have to attend in person unless
there is a reason that is you cannot for
unless it's not reasonably practicable
so so in your experience 18 years of
public meetings where would you draw the
line um you mentioned the person who's
got knee surgery obviously they're bad
written um but where would you draw that
um I think it's a good question
obviously there's a certain amount of
subjectivity in there but the word
reasonable is used throughout law and
there's a lot of litigation around what
reasonable is
um I think the spirit of the legislation
is clear that in person is preferable so
there's a preference for being in person
and I think when people are elected we
take our jobs very seriously and I think
it certainly is my preference to be in
person when I can and so I would expect
that people would interpret it in
a rather restrictive way that
reasonableness would would be things
that have to do with health things that
have to do with physical accessibility
if someone is thinking that they may be
exhibiting symptoms of something that
they would like to be careful about
spreading I would assume it would apply
to something like that I don't think
that it would apply to saying oh I I
Have a scheduling conflict and I have to
prioritize this other meeting I don't
think that would be to me that wouldn't
be reasonable I think when you're a
public servant you know that's part of
what you've done but I also think that
there's a fails safe built in here if
people are abusing this presumably they
won't be
reelected right and so we also have we
have reasonableness that's going to be
determined by initially by that person
by that public official but then we also
have the voters who are ultimately going
to determine whether they think that
person has been using reasonable in in a
reasonable
way thank you any other
questions see none thank you for coming
down
kraan thank
Burns good morning everyone I'm Margaret
Burns I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Municipal Association and
we are here in support of Senate bill
344 as you know and as has already been
stated during the pandemic when the
state of emergency was in effect
emergency order number 12 gave public
bodies significant flexibility with
regard to holding public meetings via
virtual means either entirely virtual or
allowing more remote attendance than
would normally be allowed under the
current statute after that emergency
order was lifted we continued to hear
from members that they saw really great
results from having that fle flexibility
during the state of emergency not just
the ability of elected officials to
participate when there was a reason that
kept them from being able to come out to
the physical meeting space but also many
communities saw this incredible influx
of the public attending virtually
because it was simply easier for them to
fit it into their lives and to engage
that way whether they were just
listening to the meeting or whether they
were also participating in public
comment that way and so for that reasons
our and for those reasons our members
have asked us to support legislation
that would give more flexibility for
remote meetings Senate Bill 344 is an
extremely narrow local option so it is
much narrower than emergency order 12
was and it is much narrower than Senate
Bill 344 originally was when it was
originally filed it is at its heart a
local option it says right there in line
three that a legislative body must adopt
this provision for it to be effective so
for the majority of our cities and towns
or for the majority of our towns that is
the voters at town meeting must adopt a
warrant article that authorizes use of
this local option um for the few Town
Council towns and the cities that have
the legislative body as their Council or
as their Board of aldermen that would be
the body that would have the authority
to adopt this local option as would have
the authority to adopt other local
options the additional restrictions have
already been mentioned you have to have
a quart one quarter present uh the video
must be on during the meeting you must
recess and and adjourn if there's
problems accessing the public meeting
and really a variety of safeguards in
place meant to ensure that public
meetings through virtual means are not
used to disenfranchise either elected
officials or the public that they are
actually used for the benefit of both
the public and the public body and just
as this local option can be adopted it
can similar be similarly be rescinded in
the same ma manner via a legislative
body action it's very important too and
this will be my last point that this
bill does not affect any currently
existing authority of public bodies
under RSA 9182 so I think representative
Horgan asked would this sort of undo the
ability of public bodies to have the
phone conference call remote
participation that they've been using
for a very long time that has been in
statute long before the pandemic and
long before the State of Emergency the
answer is no this does not undo current
authority to have a quorum of a public
body present and allow a member or
members to remotely participate and it
importantly does not allow the authority
of a board to have an emergency meeting
defined as when immediate and necessary
action is required it does not remove
that Authority to have an emergency
meeting with less than a quorum
physically present in those very narrow
circumstances so this is truly an
additional Authority tacked on to the
end of 91 A2 only to be exercised if the
legislative body wishes to adopt it and
so for those reasons we support Senate
Bill 344 and I would be happy to take
any questions there any questions from
Miss Burns yes representative
wer uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my my question um legislative
body must approve is that the council
and the city council or is that the
voters or the you know same thing in a
town is it the Selectmen or the or the
uh borders themselves in a town with a
town meeting form of government it is
the voters it is the people at town
meeting who would have to vote on a
warrant article in our 13 cities the
legislative body is the board of
aldermen and the city council so that
would be be the legislative body in
those communities that would have the
power to adopt this local
Sylvia thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question getting back to
the previous discussion of uh reasonably
practical and the requirement that uh
only a quarter of the public body needs
to be there for a quorum that means 3/4
of the body
is reasonably practically unable to
attend
um I have a hard time understanding what
kind of reasonable and practical has
three4 of the body
missing this one of the scenarios where
it would apply is when you have a thre
member select board occasionally you
have two members who are sick or one who
has just had surgery or one one who has
child care and must stay home with that
child and one who has covid and in those
circumstances the board wishes to
continue to have its regularly scheduled
meeting and conduct its business but
current law would not allow them to do
that because they would need a quorum of
two in order to be able to hold that
public meeting and so this really gives
flexibility in those types of
circumstances and to the conver ation
about the terminology reasonably
practical I can tell you that at nhma we
recommend that members that
municipalities construe reasonably
practical narrowly right so cannot get
out of something that prohibits them
from physically being at the meeting
space surgery illness um they're a
primary caregiver for a child or an
adult and they're unable to leave their
physical location and come to the
meeting space and that is how we
encourage public public bodies to treat
reasonably practical thank you represent
weather representative
mlan thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my district um has
Lichfield and Manchester in it so the
way that this law is written my
constituents in lynfield I'm assuming it
would be a ballot question uh that would
come about and so if the legislative
body the people of litfield wanted to do
it they they would have the voice to say
yes or no um however in Manchester um
the citizens of Manchester those
constituents really wouldn't have that
choice it would be left to the board
itself to decide and and if the citizens
of Manchester said that we really don't
want that we we really this doesn't work
for us that voice is kind of denied to
them under this bill what would be your
thoughts you know about amending this to
maybe say if has to be on a ballot
question or something like that you know
for the cities and towns because I just
see a difference with respect to
fairness between the cities and towns
and and how it's implemented I guess my
response to that would be that the
voters are getting the voice in both
circumstances but they're just different
types of government in those two
different communities that you've
referenced so in Lichfield yes
everything essentially goes to the
voters at Town meeting because that's
the structure of government that that
has been adopted in that community in
the city of Manchester they have a
representative form of government
essentially where that is the structure
of the Manchester City government and
the voice of Voters is going through
their elected council members who act as
the legislative body in that
municipality so it's consistent in both
communities because that's the form of
government and that's the way that local
options and ordinances are adopted in
both of those two different types of
questions I guess one question do you
think it would be practical at all if
you made it a requirement that the
approve legislative approval be done on
basis
I'm not sure I would object to that um
you know because of course voters can of
course we're talking about a town
meeting form of government voters could
petition at any annual meeting to resend
it right so if it was adopted last year
and they don't feel it's working well or
they don't want it anymore a group of
Voters could put it on the warrant and
and get it uh rescinded but the idea of
having it being a standing renewal
question I don't see any immediate
Horan thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Kate Horan I
serve as the executive director for the
New Hampshire Association of counties
which is all your elected and appointed
officials at the County government level
uh we are in support of this bill
primarily for our association we have a
50 member Statewide board that has
difficulties meeting their quum
requirements we've already made changes
in our bylaws that are allowable under
law to make me meeting our Quorum easier
however we still have problems for
example on Friday I may have to cancel
my meeting because everyone's going to
be away for Easter break this would
allow us to have our meetings and make
sure that our business is conducted
efficiently and effectively so that we
can come here and tell you how
legislation will impact governments we
also have over 15 subcommittees and
Affiliates that are all Statewide Susan
craigan who is here she works with the
register she's the register of from arac
trying to allow our 10 registers of
Deeds to get together to have an
affiliate meeting when the Register of
Deeds office is extremely overwhelmed
with uh requests and information and
deeds with all of the uh real estate
exchanges that are going on now would be
great right now they call an emergency
meeting every couple months because they
have to get together and they have to
meet to make decisions but that's the
only way that they can meet they can't
take time away from their offices
because they are so under staffed um it
would also help out your uh local County
governments uh for those of you who are
in the Western and Northern portions of
the state sometimes it can be snowing in
one portion of the county and not
snowing in another portion of the county
but we would still like to have our
meeting and allowing people to
participate remotely would be very
effective uh I did participate with
representative welper in the study
committee on House Bill 108 and this
bill does include many of the
recommendations that came out of that
study committee this is a very narrowly
targeted bill that will help us
accomplish our work thank you Mr
chairman I'm happy to take any questions
that the committee has questions from
Miss
Horgan
representative
Horgan um yes um with regards with
regards to the county um it's a little
bit ambiguous who the legislative body
for the county is is it the county
delegation or is it but we have very
limited powers though so like so would
it be the county delegation or would it
have to be the entire uh entire
legislature who sets the uh who would
who would have to pass a uh who' have to
decide whether or not they want to use
this procedure in their County for at
the county level it is the county
delegation and representative mlan to
answer your question because Margaret
and I literally just did this exercise
for another committee there is no
practical way to put a warrant article
and a in front of every single Community
every single year take Hillsboro for
example the towns vote in March some of
them vote in May on the alternate town
meeting day Manchester meets every other
year in October there's no way to do
that and is that really the right place
for uh questions to be decided by the
the County government at the Town level
we would argue no that that should be
handled by the county delegation so if
Hillsboro's County delegation decides no
we don't want to have this remote
meeting option you don't have to do it
and I think that's the great thing about
this
bill other
questions see none thank you for your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on Senate Bill
seeing no one we'll declare the hearing
closed and I think that concludes our
business this morning I'll just remind
the Republicans that we do have a caucus
schedule for this afternoon at 1:00 in
room 206
208 is there anything else that we need
to address and of course for everybody
we have executive session tomorrow
morning 9:00 in our usual committee
everybody
e